[Music]
[Applause]
pan Corrections this is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
now so far
millions of challengers not one winner
we mean I don't I don't know of any
other show in the world that challenges
people to find an error we have no one
can find a flaw in our show I know
because it's flawless
it's flawless it's a flawless prep no
perfection every night day in day out
right right two fans named Ben and Nick
think they caught a mistake they say it
happened during a recent comedy bit hey
Conan this is Nick so so we were
watching Conan the other day and you
were doing a bit about celebrity income
breakdown and you made a joke about
Kylie Jenner 26% of her money comes from
tweeting photos of lips 26 percent comes
from tweeting photos of but forty eight
percent compound interest from small cap
neutral fund investment Wow yeah very
wise in doesn't it yeah didn't see that
one coming did you we gave you the old
snippet rule woo did you say slipper oh
I think he said slipper ooh
think you meant switcheroo I think you
meant switcheroo the old switcheroo
[Applause]
I think we've got you Conan yeah let's
see you try and get out of this one and
don't give us the old switcharoo you
suck
he's right there I do suck
well sorry Ben and sorry Nick
but you're both dead wrong I didn't mean
to say old slipper ooh please let me
explain I said that 48% of kylie
jenner's income comes from compound
interest from small cap mutual fund
investment but let's dig a little deeper
shall we according to Charles Schwab's
guide to financial independence there
are several different types of mutual
funds money market funds fixed income
funds equity funds etc but we're talking
small cap here and let's be clear about
that small cap according to the street
the Aberdeen small cap a with an overall
rating of a plus and a risk rate of B
minus is about as good as you're gonna
get right now okay but what does that
have to do with the old slipper Oh Andy
I am so glad you asked according to
Merrill Lynch and every other financial
institution on Wall Street what our
small cap neutral funds commonly called
they're called Oh
what there call the old slip it oh yes
and and that's what they've been called
for over 100 years
take it away filmmaker Ken Burns in 1882
Marcus Goldman joined forces with
son-in-law
Samuel sax to form the investment
banking firm of Goldman Sachs Sam Sachs
was an eccentric man known for a
peculiar personal habit he always wore
bedroom slippers to work a few years
later the two men clashed over the issue
of small cap mutual funds in the heat of
the moment
Sam sacks removed one of his slippers
and threw it at his old partner
sadly Goldman died in those things there
was nothing you could do for any
injuries whatsoever but from that day
forward the small cat mutual fund became
known as the old slipper room as
forbidden men who have been proven to be
fools let us just say you sock
yeah well history it's never wrong the
challenge still stands if you think you
supporting an arrow on our show reporter
Tim koco.com / haha I found an error
we'll sort it out right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chump meat out of the maestro we'll
be right back
you